there was a time when Donald called me
up and said hey I want you to speak at
the Republican convention it was weird
because I I was actually a Hillary
Clinton supporter I was really into her
did you get asked the same thing I would
imagine he wanted you to endorse him
yeah he wanted me to speak at that
convention too and I think that I wasn't
going to do anything political like I
met him in 2001 and 2002 he asked me
after it were my first Super Bowl to to
go judge a Miss USA competition which I
thought was the coolest thing in the
world he would call me after games and I
watched your game Tom and you know let's
play golf together so 2003 2004 but and
now and then the whole political aspect
came and I think I think I got brought
into a lot of those things because it
was so polarizing around the election
time that you know was uncomfortable for
me because you know you can't undo
things and not that I would undo a
friendship but you know the political
support is totally different than the
support of a friend right you know
wouldn't you like whatever when you tell
him no I won't speak at the Republican
convention
was he pissed at you I mean was it a
walk word was that for you I imagine you
get asked to do a lot of stuff I didn't
want to get into all the political
because again it's it's a no-win 50% of
the people feel easier or winning
anything when you in regards to that
because what works it's it's politics so
but Tom the other big thing was that
Trump always dreamed of you marrying
Ivanka and he told me he suggested it to
you but did you ever take him did you
ever go out with her did you know I'm
gonna consider dating her yeah no there
was never there was never that where we
ever do anything like that I think I
married the most amazing woman and so I
had no real answer